well Muhammad sharawi is Professor of
conflict resolution and diplomacy at
George Mason University joins us here in
the studio good to have you with us so
first of all let's start with what's
behind this withdrawal of some
reservists well definitely there is a
struggle in achieving certain objectives
in Gaza therefore there is number of
those soldiers who were killed and there
is a probably latent fatigue among
certain brigades therefore I think the
military leadership is
reshuffling uh its troops with the hope
of focusing on certain narrow targets
instead of an
open-ended uh coverage of the war or you
know invol so there is a shift going on
in the military tactics I think it is I
mean the indicators are there that there
are two shifts one political and one
military and they both coincide you know
at the end of 23 beginning 24 therefore
there are questions to be asked whether
there is a trajectory that can be
determined by the government of
Netanyahu or he is trying to experiment
with other tactics here and there but
this doesn't mean the end of the war no
unfortunately the lingering Gaza war is
shifting into a protracted conflict
which may stay with us for another year
and when Netanyahu said it bluntly the
war will continue for many more months
that's an indication that he wants to
maintain his option that there is a Time
framework open ended for himself and
this is also an indication that he has
not achieved what he thought he would
achieve on the 8th of October is the
economic cost of the war also reason for
this
redeployment possibly but I think the
the impact of the economy will trigger
more uh ramifications later on so so now
you have billions of dollars that are
spent know on this military campaign in
Gaza at the same time the Israeli
economy will be suffering long term so
if there is any prediction when
Netanyahu will be convinced to change
his you know military mind that would be
uh because the Israeli economy will no
longer Bear all these consequences at
the same time the question now is with
these two sh sh s in the government as
well as in the military strategy how
does he deal with Washington I think so
far Washington has not said a word yet
about what should happen next in terms
of negotiation in terms of truce or
ceasefire or the two- State solution all
right so a new year has begun where is
Israel's military strategic interests is
it better placed now when we look at the
situation it's Southern border still
very much you know under the line of
fire the northern border unstable and
part of shipping to Israel also
disrupted it's a mixed uh situation one
objective which is
depopulating Gaza basically it's working
I think now about 80% of gazans cannot
leave anywhere so it's massive
destruction therefore there is this
school thought that gazans will be
encouraged as SM put it will be
encouraged to migrate elsewhere so the
civilian Devastation Is On Target as far
as one can tell however the military
campaign in terms of eradicating Hamas
and killing the so-called terrorists and
so forth doesn't seem to be working well
so all these indicators are boiling down
to one thing that the more time nanu is
giving himself the more latent challenge
he is facing all right thank you so much
Muhammad
shawi